on sulawesi island in the district of
purihimoto
a familiar scene the aftermath of
another illegal mining disaster in
indonesia
authorities believe there were 22 people
here when the mine collapsed
but survivors told local media there
could have been more
military police and the local disaster
agency are working together to assist
the community makeshift wooden frames
built on
unstable soil broke down during the
night first responders faced the
challenge of searching for survivors
in the dark we are doing search and
evacuation by emptying the stagnant
water and it's quite difficult because
of darkness
fatalities at unauthorized mines are
common in mineral-rich indonesia
attracting thousands of unskilled
laborers with no training or proper
safety equipment
experts estimate there are close to 9
000 unlicensed mines
around a quarter of them gold
in 2019 at least 16 people were killed
when a mine collapsed
also on the island of sulawesi duttam is
an advocacy network for safer and more
sustainable mining
it has long pushed for comprehensive
investigations into illegal operations
many people in local governments and law
enforcement are involved in it
they conduct raids close the mines down
and just a few months later the
operation is back on
local environmental groups say it is up
to the government to help these
communities
find more sustainable and less risky
work
the situation for cacao farmers in
central sulawesi is not good
they are in a bad economic condition so
they have to risk their lives in these
mining pits
it's dangerous and often low paid work
but those who keep returning to these
mines
say they have no choice jessica
washington al jazeera
jakarta